The question pose by a sister on the
YouTube. If I sew such clothes which
expose the upper part of the chest,
cleavage and shoulder don't show, so is
it halal earning haram? I believe the
question posed is that talking about a
tailor stitching clothes for a lady
where the upper part of the chest is
seen and the cleavage and the shoulder
is seen. So is it halal to stitch such
clothes? First you should realize what
is the purpose of these clothes. You
know normally when you stitch
undergarments but natural it's possible
to show the cleavage and it's perfectly
fine because the clothes worn under
under the other clothes but if there are
other clothes where you know that a lady
is wearing clothes only amongst the
ladies and if some part of the body is
exposed then it's not haram but wearing
such clothes otherwise outside it is not
permitted. So depending upon the clothes
that if you know that you're stitching
clothes for ladies who are going to wear
an abaya on top of that then it's
perfectly fine but if you know that
you're stitching designer clothes and
people wear these clothes not wearing
clothes not wearing a coat over it or
wearing an abai over it and if you're
aware of it stitching such clothes is
not permitted because Allah says in the
Quran in surah maida chapter number 5
verse number two that help one another
in righteousness and tawa do not help
one another in sin and ranker. So if
you're making clothes which you're aware
that ladies will be wearing for parties
and exposing the body and would be
involved in things which are haram then
it is not correct to stitch such
clothes. But if you know these clothes
are worn at home it's not worn the
ladies are not going to wear it in front
of the naram there are some Muslim
countries where you know people wear aa
so if you know that it is not going to
involve any haram action then there's no
problem. But if you're aware that this
will be worn by ladies who normally go
for parties outside and they don't wear
the hijab and you are specially catering
to them then it is not permitted for you
to help them in doing haram activity you
should not stitch that clothes. So
depending upon how it's going to be used
and you as a tailor know better your
customers. So based on that you have to
decide whether or what you're doing is
haram or halal. Hope that answers the
question.